23 years 23 told ya 23 years that you
serve yeah very impressive
which leads me to believe that you would
be in shape you gotta stay in shape
right it would make you think that but
yeah but not the case no but I
understand you run marathons is that
right I did I've run two marathons I ran
the New York Marathon in 2002 and then I
ran the Chicago Marathon last year okay
why the long gap in between were you
finishing the first marathon yes
basically that was half of it yeah and
then I you know I just took up smoking
for okay you don't see a lot of marathon
or puffing away as they when is this
gonna end
yeah yeah yeah you just you were
shooting a movie with Kevin Hart and it
was right before Kevin ran the New York
City Marathon that's right he ran the
New York City Marathon this year yes and
he you know Kevin who I know a little
bit he is very very serious about his
workouts and I imagine him training for
a marathon he would be incredibly
focused about that he is one of the most
disciplined guys and one of the
hardest-working guys and funny yep
I love Kevin all right I just gonna put
it out there yeah but he is amazing and
he got we were shooting long hours in
October and you know we're shooting a
night and day and he didn't matter he
didn't miss a workout he would get up
and he would do a 17 mile run and then
show up to set and so he was very
disciplined and and worked really hard
to run this marathon I never worked out
did you give you any advice about
running a marathon no I gave him some
advice though I told him about the you
know protect the nipples
people underestimate that what happens
what people jump out and grab your
nipples while you're running what
happens yeah yeah yeah
they do going in yeah yeah they do they
do they enjoy out I didn't believe you
until you went they do it they do
I mean parked cars they come out of
nowhere yeah
they have drones with pincers on it so
it's too late so what is that but yeah
like when you run 26 when you run 26
miles everything's gonna chafe it's just
it is you can't help it so even like
weird place like under your arms where
anything in motion and your shirt goes
here so you know people used to put
band-aids or tape or whatever but they
actually have these Valerie tasty thank
you yeah yeah they're like nipple rings
but they're not they don't go through
there just like doughnuts that go around
and believe me gosh and tape around a
crime scene
you put that around your nipples and it
protects them totally and I you know
they look ridiculous and you feel
ridiculous put them on but they were the
best they were awesome so I told I said
protect those bad boys and I said and
don't be afraid to put a little Vaseline
down low what's that all about what's
the Vaseline for like I said a lot of
friction a lot of you know 26 miles is a
lot two things are moving around and so
out of pretty much Vaseline do you put
down there that much you to shove it
down then either a slather it's a metric
system when you can make noises like
that that was my best guess down there
there's like yeah
right and then you jam it in there so
when you're running yeah okay
it's funky I would think so it's super
fun cuz things heat up down there and
you got hot oil moving around yeah well
don't be we're talking great weights
discussing technique you people were all
freaked out that's on you that's thank
you Conan two great athletes discussing
technique yeah I'm with Nellie Wow sir
all right so I don't know if Kevin did
any of that but you think no he didn't
take any of my series he actually trains
with real people who know what they're
doing so I'm sure he but he he I'm sure
he and he had a great race too he ran a
great marathon so I was really really
happy for
you